I have a story about a matter that I
sell that's very close to home and it
illustrates the reason America has been
able to grow and the reason and the way
of constitutional government works the
story is the founding of this college I
think it's a really great story - a New
England preachers came West out to the
frontier in Michigan in the 1840s and
they started a college 30 miles from
here up in Spring Arbor and they moved
it down to what is now a little bitty
Hillsdale it was a little then to get to
a big town and they went from town to
town and they asked who would give some
money to locate a college and the city
fathers of Hillsdale gave $15,000 on
condition that these founders including
a man named ransom Dunn would match it
they met in the city hall to make the
deal the city hall didn't have any
government official in it in fact most
government was purely voluntary back
then and well into the 20th century it
was in America but it's interesting now
they started the college they started it
in juxtaposition and in service to the
principles of the United States of
America its freedom they were
abolitionists and its constitutional
form of rule and they thought learning
the great books was necessary to
preserve that now the end of my story is
the fruits of that because it just so
happens in July of 1863 there was a big
old battle down in Gettysburg and there
was a place called the wheat fields and
we had at least forty boys there in a
place that changed six times six times
nobody had taught those boys military
science when they were at Hillsdale
College they had been taught to love Nia
and understand the purposes of our
country and so all of the young men I
say there were 30 or 40 boys in that
particular place and a company of the
Michigan forth we had over 500 young men
go joined the Union Army and that's
nearly all the young men and nobody ever
told them they had to and just like
today our kids join the military and
serve the country but you see if you
carry in your
own heart the love of the principles of
your country then in time of need
you will rally to serve them and that is
a potentially infinite point but force
and that means anything can happen any
fine and wonderful thing can happen if
you govern people as free people